What I want to do
in this video is
write the algebraic expressions
that represent the same thing
that these statements
are saying.
So this first statement, they
say the sum of negative 7
and the quantity 8 times x.
So the sum-- so we're going
to have an addition here--
of negative 7 and the
quantity 8 times x.
So the quantity 8 times
x, well, that's just 8x.
So I can just write
8x over there.
So it is negative 7 plus 8x.
Or you could view this
as the sum of negative 7
and the quantity 8 times x.
Let's do the next one.
Take the quantity negative
3 times x and then add 1.
So the quantity
negative 3 times x,
we can write that
as negative 3x.
And then we need
to add 1 to that.
So that's going to be plus 1.
Now this one.
Negative 6 plus--
so we can write
negative 6 plus something-- the
product of negative 1 and x.
So the product of
negative 1 and x,
that's just going to
be negative 1x, which
is the same thing as negative x.
So we can write this as
negative 6 plus negative x.
Or we can just
write this-- this is
the exact same thing
as negative 6 minus x.
And we are done.